incognito mode is watching you a class  action lawsuit was filed against Google  and there are several billion dollars at  stake the main claim being made by  several U.S states is that incognito  mode is not so private after all Google  Chrome's Engineers have also confirmed  people's suspicions here's what one of  them wrote in their work chat we need to  stop calling it incognito and stop using  the Spy icon  in incognito mode you and your  geolocation are still visible your  service provider the websites you visit  cyber criminals anyone if they want to  can find out what you wanted to hide so  what is incognito mode 4 anyway in  reality in this mode you're just telling  your browser not to save the browsing  history cookies and cash for the  duration of the session that's it  subscribe to sumsup and we'll tell you  how you can actually hide in the online  jungle